bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessero
video sono fatti j
volevo dirvi la prima di cominciare che
questo video è vecchio di sei mesi cioè
tipo non lo so mi pare che era fosse di
di aprile c'è una roba vecchissima
comunque ragazzi ha voluto metterlo
adesso perché siccome sono andato in
america quindi ci sono tanti buchi di
video ho voluto metterlo se sono lavoro
messo perché non mi piaceva molto
parlamento uguale spero che vi piaccia
ragazzi spero che vi piaccia
buona visione una capretta rijeka
privata cavallo lo scopo di questo gioco
quale fare cazzate
tu non puoi fare tu non puoi fare
benzina
no voleva salutarlo giu sì che la
sveglia e cazzo in fase di uscita
bagarre e pulire i prezzi che calibra
mozzata di brutto
chiamate 29 davanti avanti ma è
bellissimo 9 questo meritorio ciò che
dell'anno gioco dell'anno ma basta a
morire
avverto che cazzo è possibile
prima di tutto protesta merda io non ho
mai visto una cosa così hai messo
manager cose che cazzo impappinato non
lo so se è normale allora queste scene
ecco commossa chrome ha gentilmente ha
chiamato a colpire un costo di benzina
per farcela
sì ma quale la faccia gli sto tizio che
bella che chiamiamo sappiamo se no
perché non esaltante la viva 6 parisi 6
siamo ancora vivi siamo soltanto facendo
una passeggiata tranquilli tante preso
anche alvaro kiss
tel aviv cela se tu lasciarli morire in
mezzo alla strada era più sicura perché
c'è una chiappa incastrata lega è la mia
anima gemella aspetta c'era ma spero
questa erotico ragazzo
questi
wapa giustizia per quanto pare una cosa
non c'era prima
lol cos'è sta merda non aveva illuso chi
satanico viola calcio dirò la mia
geraghty riaccende la picchia traun 2
aspetta aspetta insieme
ciao ragazzi non per dire ma secondo me
sei stupido non aveva il video ma ce
l'ha solo l'audio non potevo caricarlo
su youtube per che tipo è si fa e dura
da parte di dio e questo stupro di già 3
guarda che schifo è una cosa normale la
barchetta premi su premi e morto è morto
tristi ma dobbiamo deve uscire lui cioè
mese abbiamo messo un ora ma abbiamo una
cappelliera sa mica queste potenti nella
capitale torna indietro ha vinto ed ho
fatto trovare
la regista mossa club amiche che si
stava già basta perché oggi io sono
diventato una camera successo mameli
giacche di botta madonna è fortissima io
l'ho vista male sono girati a sinistra
destra testing magari 90 è una delle due
vasta che ne fai una chi è quel tizio
vado ad una cosa devi fare
ma varca che non è possibile facendo
scusate scusate non ho fatto nulla
avete fatto della must amoreggiando del
como che è una cosa normale è una pace
anche mazzo di lei o di pedica romantico
checco prova a fare il centro alla
finestra c'è chi attende i miei fiori ai
balconi c'è chi attende del capri
no perché s'è lamentata perché ora come
do armi che angioletti e carino ma
com'era che palleggia guardamiglio
guardalo amica oddio
temo che questa la nuova giostra 5 euro
5 euro 5 capra contro chi la fa e vince
capra ma io io faccio di posto ho visto
grande due belle primo era era
[ __ ]
ho vinto anche se guarda li guardano il
curi dopato di merda di morire canestro
quasi questo queste forte scalciava
scalciava scalcia oh
la casa a [ __ ] del camp nou che si è
alzata ho vinto eccoli
eccolo lì oddio sono una zia che cazzo è
detto stufo e diventa ragazzi è una
giraffa un po magra cosa sono diventato
uccidetemi per favore qualcuno mi uccida
è una cosa tutti e cazzo fa non è
normale manara le sue tappe capra alta
magra giusto voglio fare di chi ma i
magri saltelli colom a fuoco tra andava
a fuoco sino all'area beccato lo ha
beccato la roccia che tu ci credono
bella e la stein è la è l'acqua e la
anche investito da ha fatto tutto lui ha
fatto io non ho fatto un cazzo non è
normale non mi fa mi leccare le cose
ecco il collo così non so che cazzo pole
e care prova bene e questa è la triste
fine della della capra alta magra
quindi io posso rubare un posto rubare i
vasi se qualcuno fosse la finestra in
questo momento sarebbe tipo una cosa
strappo aggiorniamo a dei testimoni di
geova non mi cacciano i [ __ ] a chi
fa eccolo eccolo eccolo lì è superman
[Musica]
fresco come rimasto servizio non è
normale che sia rimasto a testa in giù è
una coppia ok perfetto va a sull'albero
no niente da fare la colletta mi dà un
passaggio in gita grazie
ok come non detto sì ecco l'ultimo posto
passato stato stato madonna di mamma mia
mamma mi ha troppo troppo apro hugin in
un video solo questo tizio che vista
abbastanza sul cui io lo prenderei lo
tipo a pesca
ecco non hanno preso fermi che non lo
riesco alle care eccola lì ragazzi ce
l'abbiamo e nel carnet fermi che devo
recare il deltaplano cioè no io devo
prenderla rinco no questa è veramente
impossibile
cisco milano fare santo san fa vj si dio
mio
c'è il culo ragazzi giova non ci posso
credere non ci voglio che non è
possibile non è fottutamente possibile
ho preso un deltaplano con una giraffa
buongiorno come edi chiesti casa mio
culo di preciso non era bellissimo che
contenta tele sembra soddisfatta per mi
fermi fermi fermi in giacche trick con
l'arco alla faccia si è rimasta appesa
non importa gas skaters con una cosa
romanticissima una capra che volteggia
non lo so vabbè dai dopo questo posso
ritenermi freestyler nato nove ragazzi
comunque era è stata la stronzata ma
doveva assolutamente farla
chiudiamo qui prima che le stronzate
diventino eccessive tipo questa è
comunque giunto un orchila episodio
lasciamo perdere tutto racca pronta
comunque aveva il suo stile inter va bè
ragazzi come al solito seguito mi è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche a vari facebook e condivido tante
una descrizione se ne verifichi scrive
alieni ci vediamo prossimo video ma non
c'è reazione staccato anche le pile
brava fini ragazzi il video è concluso
spero che mi sia piaciuto anche se
era appunto molto vecchio quindi è un po
diverso dalla vj che avete oggi spero
comunque che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
come al solito servito da vestito la
stanza un commento mi piace anche a face
di facebook e come noi video trovate ad
estinzione forse dovresti discreti i
civili devono prossimo bella ragazzi